hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
efficient cold sample storage reducing
the environmental footprint
and financial impact of freezer use and
research
i'm christy jewell of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by brooks life sciences
for more information on our sponsor
click on the sponsor logo at the left
side of your screen
or visit brookslifesciences.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
also please notice that you can share
this webinar on your personal social
media
just click on the social sharing tab on
the left to let your friends and
colleagues know about today's live
events
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing today's presentation
click on that support tab down at the
top right of your presentation window
or just use that ask a question box to
let us know you're experiencing a
problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
we have two presenters for you today dr
catherine ramirez aguilar
cu green labs program manager university
of colorado boulder
and board of directors international
institute for sustainable laboratories
also joining us is christina griever
operations manager for my green lab
for complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome kathy and christina you may now
begin your presentations
thank you for the introduction christy
my name is kathy and as christie
mentioned i manage the university of
colorado
green labs program and i'm also on the
board for the international institute
for sustainable labs
it's great to be with you here today to
talk about
efficient cold storage you know it
wasn't long after starting
the cu green labs program just over 10
years ago that i was lucky to partner
with a few other colleagues at other u.s
universities that had also started green
labs programs
at their institutions in those early
days of green lab efforts
efficient cold storage was a natural fit
for us to focus on for energy efficiency
in labs 10 years later the cu green labs
program continues to work on energy
efficiency with laboratory freezers
among many other efforts at cu boulder
such as those that focus on water
efficiency in labs recycling and
materials leaving the lab
and also two of my favorite areas of
focus
which are enhancing the sharing of
research equipment and efficient use of
laboratory space
because efforts on these two topics can
have such large positive impacts
for avoided costs and also large
positive impacts for reducing the
footprint of research on the environment
the place where the green labs community
has been connecting with each other
and sharing our efforts with each other
including efficient cold storage
is the international institute for
sustainable laboratories
which will be holding its 2020
conference in chicago in october
among many other stakeholders including
engineers planners and designers
who will be involved with creating
energy laboratory buildings
are people like christina and i working
to engage scientists in efficiency
actions and laboratories as well as
research equipment manufacturers
showcasing their energy-efficient
research equipment including cold
storage units
such as energy efficient ultra
temperature freezers
so now i'll pass it over to christina
thanks kathy so my name is christina
thanks again for listening in into our
webinar today
i am the operations manager for the lab
sustainability non-profit
my green lab our mission is to build a
culture of sustainability through
science and we do this through a variety
of programs
one of which is the freezer challenge
our lab certification program which is
available to labs worldwide
complements the freezer challenge
because it also promotes the same cold
storage best practices but also covers
many other topics related to
sustainability and research
such as energy use water use waste
reduction
green chemistry fume hoods autoclave
travel and even purchasing after the
freezer challenge it is a logical next
step for labs that want to examine their
protocols and practices
to be more sustainable another one of
our program areas i want to mention is
the center for energy efficient
laboratories or seals
this is a partnership between us
kilowatt engineering and frontier energy
that works on gathering data and
conducting market studies
to get the information that the lab
sustainability community needs to
advance our field
i'm going to be referring to this again
later the migraine lab collaborates with
suppliers
academics and industry groups to develop
and share laboratory sustainability best
practices
we listen to feedback from our partners
to drive continuous improvement
in the lab sustainability field and we
also innovate new ways to engage
this community finally i just want to
mention that before i worked for my
green lab i worked for the green labs
program at cu boulder
with kathy so if it appears in this
webinar that i have an intimate
knowledge of what cu boulder does
it is because i do and i used to work
there so
just wanted to clarify that relationship
in the next few minutes we're going to
discuss the impact of cold storage on
our planet
and then i'll jump into the
international laboratory freezer
challenge and explain how that works
then we'll move into the best practices
promoted by the challenge
finally kathy will take us on a deeper
dive into the broader impacts
of efficient cold storage
so why should we as scientists think
about our cold storage anyway
well not only do laboratories have
signific have a significant energy
footprint
worldwide but our cold storage does too
refrigerators and freezers are very
common types of laboratory equipment
found in most labs in 2016 the center
for energy efficient laboratories or
seal
put out a market assessment which
surveyed the number of refrigerators and
freezers across california
there are about three ultra low
temperature freezers per lab in
california
which equates to 58 000 total in that
state
that means that there are at least 440
000 ultra low temperature freezers in
the united states
and that is just the low end of the
estimated range
one ultra low temperature freezer alone
can consume
10 to 30 kilowatt hours per day
depending on whether it is energy
efficient or not
for perspective a small single family
home in the united states
consumes about 25 kilowatt hours per day
the magnitude of the impact of cold
storage in the united states alone
is pretty incredible let alone thinking
about this on a worldwide scale
the seal market assessment estimated
that there's a minimum of 440
000 ultralows in the us with a maximum
estimate of
890 000 of them regardless of how you
look at the data we're talking about
between one and two hoover dams worth of
electricity a year
that's how much ultra low temperature
freezers are consuming in the united
states alone
this doesn't even include the energy use
of refrigerators
minus 20 degree freezers cold rooms etc
if laboratories worldwide made a
conscious effort to improve the energy
efficiency of their cold storage in
whatever way they could
this could have a measurable positive
impact on our planet
and this is exactly what the
international laboratory freezer
challenge is trying to do
the freezer challenge has now gone
global but it was actually started on a
smaller scale as a competition between
uc davis
u-boulder and a couple other
institutions that all provided input as
kathy ramirez aguilar and her colleague
alan doyle
worked out how a competition like this
could work and what it would cover
this was quite a few years ago
the freezer challenge was handed off to
i2sl and my
lab in 2017 so we are now in the fourth
year of this broader challenge
it's free to participate open to any lab
worldwide
and is supported by corporate sponsors
that manufacture refrigerators and
freezers
it might surprise you to know that
greater energy efficiency
isn't the whole point of the freezer
challenge the best practices we promote
also benefit sample accessibility
improved sample integrity
and can reduce costs for your lab and
your institution
so it's a win-win scenario for labs that
take the time to compete in this
challenge
a wide variety of laboratories
participate in the freezer challenge
each year
we have academic labs government labs
pharmaceutical and biotech labs as well
as clinical labs
that participate so far we have over 192
laboratories participating
this year
and we do know that the freezer
challenge is having positive impact
in 2019 the actions of all the
laboratories participating in the
challenge combined
save 2.4 million kilowatt hours per year
which is the equivalent of 360 passenger
vehicles driven for a year
or the energy use of 263 single-family
homes in the united states
imagine what the impact could be if
thousands of labs did the freezer
challenge
another impact of the freezer challenge
is engaging laboratories to take
sustainable action
sometimes for the very first time
pictured here are some of the labs and
institutions that won the freezer
challenge in 2019.
at the top you have the university of
illinois urbana-champaign who won the
academic category last year
charles river won the biopharma
organizational category
and the cdc one for the government
category
awards are also given to the top
individual labs in each category that
take the most actions during the freezer
challenge
so we have the organizational award
level and then the individual lab
award level the multiple sclerosis and
parkinson's tissue bank at the imperial
college london took the top academic
prize last year
they're pictured on the left pictured at
the bottom in the lab coast is the
automated strain engineering lab at
amyris
who won the biopharma industry category
and on the right
is the inorganic and radiation
analytical toxicology branch
of the centers for disease control they
were the top lab in the government
category
so participating in the freezer
challenge is very straightforward
a lab can register anytime between
october and may
and scoresheets are usually due by may
1st each year
it's quick and easy to register and then
the lab receives a score sheet that they
can work through
at their leisure over a period of weeks
or months
an organization can also have a site
coordinator if they want
and this is especially beneficial if a
university or a company wants to hold
an internal competition and wants to
know who at their site has
registered for the challenge as labs
work through the freezer challenge score
sheet
they're actively implementing the best
practices i'm about to
walk you through on this webinar the lab
then submits their completed score sheet
back to my green labs by the deadline
and we calculate scores
and the impact of their actions
finally the top labs and organizations
in each category get their photo
and recognition in the journal nature
labs and organizational winners are also
honored at the go to beyond awards lunch
at the annual international institute
for sustainable labs conference
which is taking place in chicago this
year
so the freezer challenge can be useful
to any lab that has any one of these
types of cold storage ultra low
temperature freezers
minus 20 to minus 40 degrees celsius
units refrigerators
cold rooms ultra ultra low freezers as
well as liquid nitrogen storage
the best practices highlighted by the
challenge fall into four categories
good management practices temperature
tuning
retirements and upgrades and cutting
edge practices
so there's something for any lab that
has cold storage
as a part of this challenge so let's get
into those best practices now
first of all to be clear this photo here
depicts what you
don't want to be striving for look at
all of that ice
this uh freezer has clearly not been
defrosted in a while
the boxes can barely fit on the shelves
you don't want your freezer to get to
this point
obviously it's important to periodically
defrost freezers
whether that be on a schedule set by the
labs such as every year
or when you start to see ice build up
don't wait for it to get this bad
other important preventative maintenance
is to remove dust from the intake areas
of your cold storage units and gently
vacuum the cooling coils underneath
finally as often as necessary gently tap
ice from around
your door seal and brush ice off of the
inner doors
be very gentle so you don't damage the
door seal of your
freezer these are very expensive to
replace
this next set of best practices are all
related to the samples that you store
inside your cold storage unit be sure to
do periodic sample cleanouts
every six months or every year is a
great idea
have an inventory system whichever
method works for your lab
but then stick to it update your
inventory as needed
if you have cold storage units with a
lot of empty space
try consolidating your units down so you
can unplug or retire
a newly empty unit by consolidating your
samples this will actually allow your
freezer to run more efficiently
and your door openings will have less
impact all the cold air won't be falling
out of your freezer
finally if your samples allow it convert
from standard 10 by 10 freezer boxes to
higher density formats
so what's the why behind these best
practices
ensuring your freezers are periodically
defrosted and consistently de-iced means
that your freezer will have the proper
internal airflow
that was intended by its design ice can
get in the way of this
furthermore your door should close
properly if you keep the ice away
and your door should not leak any cold
air proper internal airflow
will ensure that there is greater
temperature uniformity in your cold
storage unit
which improves sample integrity for the
long term
your freezer won't have to work as hard
when there is proper air flow too
heavily iced over freezer can consume
more energy than normal so defrosting is
also beneficial for energy efficiency
removing dust from intake areas and
coils also positively impacts the
efficiency of your unit
consider this for every minute an
ultra-low temperature freezer that is in
in an upright model so an upright ultra
low
every minute that that freezer door is
open
it takes 10 minutes for the freezer to
get back to its set point
the longer the door is kept open the
harder your compressors or engine must
work to cool your freezer back down
this impacts energy consumption of your
unit but also affects
sample integrity without an effective
inventory
you are exposing your samples to more
temperature fluctuations over their
lifetime
keep an inventory of your units internal
keeping it inventory will keep your
unit's internal temperature more stable
and reduce the energy consumption of
your unit and protect your samples
by doing periodic sample cleanouts
you're freeing up new space
for the storage of newer samples in your
freezers as well
this reduces the chance that your lab
will need to purchase
additional cold storage units which
impacts the long-term energy use of your
laboratory
buying a new cold storage unit should be
a critical decision
you're buying a piece of equipment that
will be on 24 hours a day
7 days a week 365 days a year until it
fails
that could be 15 20 or even 25 years
down the line
and finally higher density storage is
the best practice for the same reason
sample cleanouts are
reduce the need for more cold storage
reduced costs for your lab and
institution
at the same time
so in the category of temperature tuning
there are two main best practices
first consider whether you're storing
your samples at the appropriate
temperature
this best practice asks that scientists
consider whether for example
items stored in their ultra low could
instead be kept at negative 20 celsius
or whether items in a negative 20
freezer could be safely stored in a
refrigerator
particularly since ultra low temperature
freezers are larger energy consumers
than -20 units or refrigerators ensuring
that you're being
realistic and selective about what
should be kept at negative
70 or negative 80 degrees celsius is
beneficial
the second best practice is chilling up
ultra low temperature freezers to minus
70.
this practice has grown common at cu
boulder with 50 percent of ultra low
temperature freezers
on campus at a set point of negative 70
degrees celsius
how this started at boulder was that a
scientist had a freezer that wouldn't
maintain
negative 80 celsius anymore a technician
was called out and the technician
determined there really wasn't anything
that they could do for the freezer but
he suggested that the lab could put
their freezer at negative 70 degrees
celsius instead and they might get a few
more months out of it
so the lab did that and it worked when
stu greenlabs found out about this
instance that happened it looked around
campus for other freezers that were kept
at negative 70.
sure enough they located about five more
freezers that had always been kept
at negative 70 celsius and so they
started to promote this as an
energy-saving freezer resiliency method
kathy's colleagues at uc davis also had
freezers on campus that were kept at
negative 70. so boulder wasn't the only
one doing this
a few years ago cu boulder started a
database where scientists could record
what sort of samples they're storing at
negative 70
and for what length of time this
database is availa available to the
green labs community and we've linked to
it in the resource section of this
webinar
which is over on the left hand side of
your screen there's a whole resources
tab with a bunch of links
so this data is from a 2016 market
assessment of ultra low temperature
freezers
done by the center for energy efficient
laboratories
it shows that for different for 15
different makes and models
of ultra low temperature freezer there
is on average a 37
reduction in energy use when the set
point is at negative 70 instead of
negative 80.
therefore there are energy efficiency
benefits to both of the best practices
in this category
a freezer's compressors don't have to
work as hard a negative 70 celsius as
they do at negative 80 degrees celsius
especially with frequent door openings
this means less wear on the mechanical
components and less stress on the
freezer
keeping your freezer at negative 70 can
extend the life of your freeze dirt and
reduce the risk of catastrophic failure
all right if you do a great job with a
sample clean out or consolidate samples
from multiple units into a single
solar unit you might have the
opportunity to retire a cold storage
unit you no longer need
either turn off the unneeded unit until
you need it again
or if you need it in an emergency or you
can permanently dispose of it
when choosing which unit to dispose of
try and eliminate the most energy
consumptive units first
when considering whether to buy a new
cold storage unit be sure to take a look
at energy star rated lab refrigerators
and freezers
these have been vetted extensively
through the energy star process
and there are lots of great options by
making an energy efficient choice when
you buy
you're likely saving your institution or
company thousands of dollars over the
lifetime of the equipment
the most sure way to reduce costs
regarding your cold storage
is to unplug unneeded units and
permanently dispose of them as possible
if you reduce empty space in your units
too by consolidation
this will actually promote better
airflow and temperature uniformity
throughout the unit
if you're considering buying a new unit
be sure you're buying an energy
efficient model
for the long-term energy and cost
savings for your organization
the final category of best practices is
what we call cutting edge ideas share
space with other colleagues
in your cold storage unit either
permanently or in the event
of an emergency create barcoded
inventories for greater labeling
accuracy and for ease of sample access
or try room temperature sample storage
by sharing your cold storage space with
nearby colleagues
even those from other laboratories you
generate good will
but you but also sharing can lead to
significant cost avoidance and greater
energy efficiency among your labs
kathy is going to talk in greater detail
about this with an example from cu
boulder
bar-coded inventories can lead to better
sample accessibility and tracking
finally room temperature sample storage
has the potential
to make your lab more resilient and
reduce risk reduce risk
that is inherent with storing samples in
freezers long term
which obviously rely on a constant power
supply
by storing it at room temperature this
option is definitely more energy
efficient
it requires zero energy input migraine
lab has
information on our website about room
temperature sample storage
as does cu green labs room temperature
sample storage technology is based on
natural processes
such as how tardigrades and brine shrimp
which are extremophiles
are able to protect their dna rna
proteins
membranes and cellular systems long term
in a dried state
and later are revived by simple
rehydration
the technology works by forming a
thermostable barrier
during the drying process to protect
samples from degradation during
storage at room temperature thus far
room temperature sample storage seems
like a viable solution
for the long-term storage of dna rna and
bacteria
and there are also a lot of resources
and references you can look into
for doing room temperature sample
storage and trying that at your
institution
so with that i'm going to turn things
over to kathy
thanks christina the efforts that
christina has been talking about
for efficiency in cold storage also mean
efficiency with the funding that
scientists spend on research within labs
also known as direct costs for example
a good inventory of lab freezers and
refrigerators
means saving researcher time because it
is easier to find
samples and materials and it also means
avoiding duplicate orders of materials
or costly specialized items
because lab members can see what the lab
has on hand
and where to find it researcher time and
lab materials are both direct costs
as christina pointed out clean outs and
other ways to use freezer space more
efficiently
such as dense storage means less of a
need for labs to buy additional freezers
and other cold storage units
again a savings for direct costs
furthermore these efforts for efficiency
with cold storage
in the freezer challenge also mean
efficiency with overhead resources
and therefore overhead costs that
companies or research institutions are
paying for in support of research and
that granting agencies are contributing
to
on top of direct costs for overhead
costs at
institutions also known as indirect
costs for example
actions for energy efficiency such as
those that christina discussed
means the use of less electricity and
thus also minimization
of ventilation required to address
rejected heat into the lab space by
freezers and other cold storage units
these are overhead costs that are
reduced
additionally efficient use of space
inside freezers
and other cold storage units means
minimizing the need
for more freezers and more units which
takes up lab space
lab space is thus an overhead resource
that is used more efficiently
and when we're talking about using
laboratory space more efficiently
that can lead to large cost avoidance
because constructing new laboratory
space
and new laboratory buildings is
incredibly expensive
at cu boulder for example a thousand
square feet of new wet lab space will
cost
approximately one million dollars in a
new lab building construction project so
any effort that contributes towards
efficient use of laboratory space and
keeping lab space focused on research is
in the best interest of everyone
more efficient use of lab space means
less pressure to build
more lab buildings or additions onto lab
buildings
also wet lab space is typically very
energy intense space
especially because of ventilation
requirements
therefore minimizing the need for more
lab space also greatly benefits energy
savings
at the same time minimizing the need for
more core cold storage units in wet lab
space
also means helping to keep lab space
focused on meeting the needs of
researchers
by keeping lab space focused on research
and contributing
and contributing to the goal of helping
to make sure researchers have the space
that they need for their experiments
which leads me to the question is wet
lab space really the best place for
freezers
or are there other spaces that could be
used instead
to house freezers and thus help maximize
the use of lab space to meet research
needs
while also being more cost effective and
efficient
in my opinion the freezer challenge is a
great way to engage scientists to think
about actions that they can take for
efficient
effective cold storage which then
opens the doors to even more
conversation for even larger action
because of efforts such as the freezer
challenge and green labs programs
there is growing awareness and growing
action by scientists to minimize
research's footprint on the planet
i have been impressed with the actions
that lab members are willing to take at
cu boulder
and beyond because they want to do their
part in minimizing that footprint
as christina mentioned earlier those
campuses with a site coordinator
in the freezer challenge tend to have
the most success in the freezer
challenge
overall these efforts with the freezer
challenge open the doors to begin
thinking about
changes and actions that can take place
beyond the actions promoted by the
freezer challenge
for example the benefits that can come
from co-localization of freezers and
equipment rooms or even in freezer farms
over the years i've been learning from
colleagues and facilities management at
cu boulder
that when co-localization of cold
storage units is possible
cooling needs to address rejected heat
from the units can be addressed in a
much more localized energy efficient
manner
furthermore campus resources for backup
power for times of emergency
can be focused in on select locations
thus enabling a campus to more
strategically use funding
for backup infrastructure and therefore
be able to stretch
funding for infrastructure to serve more
backed up power needs
in an emergency because freezers hold
critical research samples
the thought is that these co-localized
spaces can be more easily
prioritized for support which benefits
resilience for cold storage samples and
research
adding a manager to oversee the co-local
co-localized cold storage units
opens the doors to even more opportunity
for benefits and efficiency
now is possible for cold storage to be a
service to researchers
there is designated personnel to make
sure that units are well cared for
and monitored to provide support to
assure good labeling and inventorying of
samples
to respond in the time of an emergency
with an emergency action plan in place
i'm sure no researcher will miss the
worry of a 2 a.m weekend phone call
about a freezer failing it can also mean
enabling easy access to freezer space
when a lab doesn't need
or want to purchase an entire ultimate
temperature freezer
because they can rent the space that
they actually need
this benefits efficient use of space
inside freezers
and thus efficient use of floor space
where managed co-localized cold storage
is possible to implement at a company or
research institution
in my opinion is unlikely that there's
going to be one solution that fits all
and thus there is likely a need for
flexibility in solutions
so the need of each unique campus can be
best met
for example could there be a more
centralized facility for archival
samples on the edge of campus but more
regional or local spaces with freezers
to meet the needs of samples that would
be accessed more frequently by
researchers
in this scenario when i say a regional
space i'm suggesting one building
with a freezer farm near a number of
other research buildings that can be
accessed by those buildings
or for samples that are accessed even
more frequently
a more localized setup could be within a
common equipment room
within a research building itself or
could there be a centralized facility to
serve both archival samples and samples
that need
to be accessed more frequently with the
ability to quickly get samples delivered
from the facility when needed
i was lucky a number of years ago to
visit an example
of this ladder idea at the university
university of minnesota
there was a freezer farm that was on the
edge of campus
and it was serving one or more
biological departments
so this was an interesting example to
visit um i would expect there are many
examples of different models out there
on other campuses
or companies that we could all learn
from in fact i bet
um there are groups focused on
biorepository work
or companies like brooks life sciences
that is sponsoring this talk
that likely know a lot about this
subject and the cost avoidances involved
for many campuses a move to
co-localization of units requires a
shift in culture
and i would expect likely an even larger
shift in culture to move in the
direction of co-localization of units
with a manager
where scientists rent space and freezers
cultural changes in my experience often
take significant time unless there is
another factor
such as a sudden event that causes the
shift quickly
like a response to a natural disaster
that will keep power out of on a campus
for an extended period of time
nyu in new york city experienced such a
disaster during hurricane sandy
that required an immediate response to
save research samples
at cu boulder our culture is still very
much where individual labs have their
own individual cold storage units
but with encouragement that culture is
being shifted over time
efforts by our facilities management to
include equipment rooms and lab building
projects
where heat producing equipment can be
placed instead
of inside the lab these are having
positive impacts
also cu green labs has been promoting a
shift
towards shared research equipment with a
manager
for the benefit of efficiency but also
for the benefit of researchers and for
campus
together because of the efforts of many
and because of our great engaged
scientists
culture is shifting on my campus in my
opinion
few green labs often highlights with
researchers and other campus
stakeholders all the different benefits
that managed equipment sharing brings
from many different perspectives
in fact we have a list of 16 reasons on
our website
most of which have nothing to do with
energy savings or the environment
and a link has a link has been provided
to this webpage in the resources
provided for this webinar
which have been told us to the left
there is
growing support among cu boulder campus
researchers for migrating towards more
and more managed
shared research equipment on campus
which can benefit for example
expanded research capability and avoided
costs for scientists
in fact our campus has just hired a
director of coors and shared
instrumentation
also space allocation principles on my
campus include sharing of research
equipment resources
and is being re promoted as part of
laboratory construction projects and
renovations
and even in buildings where there's no
construction projects being implemented
efforts such as the formation of the
biocore which is focused on enhancing
sharing of existing research equipment
resources between labs and between three
departments on campus
is having great success at the same web
page
on shared equipment that i just
mentioned there's also
a button link to report on the progress
of the
biocore during just its first year
there's also a link to a biochemistry
shared cell culture facility case study
that christina worked so hard to put
together that is another useful resource
that demonstrates the benefits to
science and the large potential for cost
avoidance that exists on campuses
for managed for managed sharing of
equipment like biosafety cabinets
incubators cold storage units or in the
case of the bio core
nano drops shakers and so much more
items really these are items that are
outside the super expensive category of
research equipment
that can often be overlooked for sharing
in research environments
this is where there is the most untapped
potential for sharing in my opinion on
research campuses
in this category of less expensive but
major research equipment resources
on the topic of freezers thanks to
thanks to significant work by christina
when she worked at cu bold boulder few
green labs has launched a program about
four years ago
aimed at growing this culture of sharing
ultimate temperature freezers
to demonstrate to campus that there are
scientists at cu boulder that want
access to cold storage
outside the culture of my lab and my
ultra low temperature freezers
we now have five freezers and four
buildings scattered across campus with
about a hundred users and six
departments
this has led to approximately a hundred
thousand dollars in avoided freezer
purchases
which of course doesn't include other
savings such as floor floor space
savings that would have been needed to
house the additional ultra temperature
freezers
and electricity and ventilation cost
savings as well
you can see a picture of two of our
units here this has been our most
popular site for this shared ultra
temperature freezer project
not long after after starting this
project
the first freezer we placed in this
building feed up filled up
quite quickly and thus we got a second
unit for this building
we wanted to encourage scientists to
move into the shared ultimate
temperature freezers
but still have to pay a fee for their
space to try to avoid samples going into
the freezers
that should have really been disposed so
we worked with our campus controllers
office to set a very affordable rate
and an attractive rate of 25 cents per
month for a two inch box
this rate is solely based on the cost to
replace the ultra temperature freezer in
six years
if rental fees were collected for a full
freezer
over the six years so this is definitely
a very subsidized rate
for example this rate does not take into
consideration other costs such as lab
space use
electricity use and importantly our time
to manage the program
lab buildings with an interest in having
a green labs shared ultimate temperature
freezer
for their scientists to easily access
have provided a location for the freezer
and labs using the freezers are required
to be responsible for their samples if
there is an emergency
thus there are lab points of contact for
each lab on the monitoring system to be
notified in an event of a freezer
failure
we intend to encourage our researchers
to purge samples that they no longer
need in the shared ultimate temperature
freezers
perhaps by having these freezers
participate in the freezer challenge
itself
it has been interesting to follow the
various reasons why researchers are
using our ultimate temperature freezers
some really only need minimal space in
in an ultra temperature freezer and thus
want to avoid the cost of a unit
in fact some researchers will rent space
for only one box
while other researchers are just
starting up their research and don't
need an entire ultra temperature freezer
yet
others want a place to house duplicate
samples for resiliency
in case something happens to their
freezer we've had a couple of labs
request space in our freezers because
they're collaborating with a colleague
in a building which is away from their
lab space in another building
they have also had researchers move into
our freezers
because they've had a freezer failure
and decided that they could downsize the
volume of their samples to the point
where it didn't make sense to buy a
replacement freezer for their lab
collectively these efforts for
efficiency that christina and i have
discussed
means being more efficient with research
sponsor funding
whether that is federal or from another
source
also being more efficient with startup
package funding research institution
costs and even company funding as well
if a scientist is writing a grant
proposal for funding why not mention
efforts being employed that benefit
efficiency
resiliency and sample integrity in the
grant proposal
why not show that your campus your
research is doing what you can
to make the most of the funding and
maximize the positive
impact of those research dollars this is
what the i2sl
bringing efficiency to research grants
or better grants effort is about
this is still a young grassroots effort
that i've been leading with partners
such as my green lab and others
as much as i can through the i2sl
university alliance group when i can
make the time
to help increase the focus on this
effort
lately we've been trying to find funding
through nonprofits that offer grants so
we can have a staff member
dedicated to this effort but even
without funding we have been able to at
least accomplish so far
the creation of an initial better grants
website
the plan is to launch a campaign to
encourage researchers at institutions
across the u.s to start voluntarily
incorporating actions for efficiency
into grant proposals such as those ideas
encouraged at this better grants
website so if you're a scientist that's
writing a grant proposal and you agree
with the idea
of connecting efficiency with the
funding of research
to maximize the effective use of sponsor
funding while also minimizing the
environmental footprint
so please do visit this site and see if
it can help with including actions for
efficiency
into your proposal send me your feedback
so we can make this website even better
and if you're willing to share an
example what you put in your proposal
please do so we can use your effort to
encourage others to take action as well
in summary the freezer challenge is a
fun competition between labs and
institutions
the challenge engages scientists which
can help lead to more action for
efficient
storage beyond the challenge such as the
idea of co-localizing using
units and efficient cold storage is a
win-win
bringing benefits for sample integrity
sample management
funding resiliency and the planet
and so i will turn it back to christina
now
here yeah so
uh my green lab and i2sl have an
announcement that
the 2020 freezer challenge deadline has
been extended to july 1st
this year so even if you're learning
about the freezer challenge for the
first time today
that still means that you have just
three months
that you could still take action and
complete a score sheet for
the challenge so feel free to visit the
website and sign up
if you haven't already and for those of
you that are already participating
we don't need your score sheets back
until july 1st
great and then i also had another
announcement um
is that the this webinar is really part
of a series of webinars
i2fl is offering the second webinar on
may 14th
which you can see here on this slide
alicia
and sean who will be doing that webinar
are are
like christina and i they're very active
members of the iqsl community
and they'll be speaking about the impact
that co-localized shared equipment
like the idea of managed co-localized
freezers mentioned
in this talk can have to benefit design
and engineering of new and renovated lab
buildings and it's my hope that they can
provide you with some
real cost examples of cost avoidances in
those projects
that result from migrating to more of a
shared equipment and shared space
culture
this webinar is also free and the
registration the registration link is
not available yet but if you email
itusses they will get you signed up
and so with that christina and i will
take
some time to answer some questions
yes
thank you kathy and christina for your
informative presentation and yes it is
time for our live q a portion of our
webinar
now to our audience if you have any
questions you would like to ask if you
haven't done so already
please do so just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
now let's get started we have some great
questions coming in
let's see okay our first question what
have you found to be the biggest
stumbling block
in adopting the best practices for
energy efficient freezer
management
um so christina here um i'll take this
first question to start with
so i think um the biggest challenge
facing labs
initially is actually committing the
time
to undertake these best practices and
implement them in the lab obviously you
know you're doing research full-time
and busy with other priorities
and so yeah devoting time to this
especially to
you know maybe give your refrigerators
and freezers
uh a reboot you know doing the
defrosting doing the preventative
maintenance
doing a sample clean out all of that you
know um
that does take some effort but like once
you do it your freezers and
refrigerators are running
more efficiently and um you know you're
better protecting your samples
so um some strategies for addressing
this
you know if your lab is motivated by
competition signing up
for the freezer challenge and making it
known that
you know your lab is doing this you're
competing with other labs worldwide
that can be a motivator for some labs
other labs have found
success in you know devoting like one
friday afternoon a month during the
freezer challenge or
year-round to kind of keeping tabs on
the preventative maintenance and other
best practices we've talked about here
just setting aside particular time
putting it on people's calendars
and making it a group effort to to
implement those best practices
so i think time is the biggest the
biggest issue
um yeah it can be overcome with with
someone in the lab to motivate
thank you now our next question and i'm
going to ask these questions to both of
you so feel free if you both have
input for these questions to both chime
in why does having ice
built up in the freezer affect
efficiency
well uh i'll just add here if you
if you have ice around the seal for the
freezer for example
then the the freezer will be um having
trouble sealing and keeping closed and
there could be leakage of air from the
freezer
and therefore you know that ice buildup
can can cause the freezer to be leaking
air out and therefore having to work
harder to maintain that temperature
yeah and to add to that um
this is christina again to add to that
you know freezers aren't designed to be
like full of ice
um you know they're not meant to be
glaciers in there so
having the proper airflow moving around
your sample boxes
um i mean that's that's how it was
intended to function and work
so um having all that ice built up
makes it less energy efficient
thank you both now is running your
freezers at negative 70 degrees
in line with cap requirements in a
biorepository
i am not sure on the answer that
question
um no i'm not familiar with that what
question number was that
christy thirty
yeah i actually don't know about cap
requirements either
for biorepositories um
you know my experience hasn't been
working
in an environment with about a
repository so
i'm not quite sure how to answer that
question but we can definitely follow up
with the person that asked
absolutely and todd we do have your
email address so we can have somebody
from
brookside science just contact you and
give you that information
let's go to our next question how would
you recommend
sorting through samples that need to be
kept at a low temperature while
discarding samples in the same
freezer
[Music]
um kathy do you want to share your
awesome
system at cu boulder
with the oh mobile freezers
yeah that's true um i mean we don't have
this for ultra temperature freezers but
one thing that we have set up for the
scientists at
um for for negative 20 temperatures is
that we've we have
a a fleet of mobile
negative 20 freezers that scientists can
borrow
so that they can uh plug that unit in to
their
in in their lab and use that unit to be
going through
the samples in their freezers um
their minus 20 freezers although we have
had scientists you see even for ultra
lows at times
but um we've also helped scientists
the green labs program at cu boulder has
helped cu boulder scientists
with finding uh backup space in ultra
low temperature freezers
that they can borrow for a while to help
make some space in their unit so that
they can then
have more easily go through the samples
within their freezer so
we we have a tendency to know what
equipment resources
in terms of freezers where they're
located on our campus
and so we often get contacted for
various
needs that our scientists have for um
for their freezers including clean outs
and we will help
um one thing like we had one lab uh
recently um that is way in in a
satellite lab that's off campus and they
had two ultra lows and
we did have a lab go through the process
to say that they really didn't need an
ultra low anymore
um it was still a functioning ultra low
and so one
way that we were able to help that lab
and that satellite situation where there
were not were no other ultra low
freezers in the same area was to provide
them
with this uh additional ultra low
temperature freezer
which is just being used as a backup so
they can plug it in
to be able to do purges and it also
provides
provides them with an emergency backup
in time if they were to ever have a
failure
but the lab is committed and we ask them
to commit to please keeping it off when
not in use because it is not
an energy efficient unit and and so yeah
that was part of the
the coordination that we did with them
but we do various things
like that example to help out i think
if you this is christina here um just to
add to that
you know ask if you if you are in a
building where there are other labs and
other ultra low temperature freezers for
example
you know ask around for if anyone has
available space even you know a shelf
here a shelf there
um and you know so perhaps you can clear
some samples out of your ultra low to
provide more space while you do
this purge of samples also obviously use
you know coolers and dry ice um you know
to pull different boxes out of the
freezer and look at them in more detail
and then put them back in the freezer
so um unless you're in a spot where
there's
absolutely no other ultra lows around
you um i think
uh you know leaning on your colleagues
and asking around for support
is a great way to tackle um a
sample clean out in an ultra low
thank you and i wanted to real quick
jump back to our question
about if running your freezers at
negative 70 degrees
is if that is in line with cap
requirements in a biorepository
and yes that is in line with the
biorepository
okay oh let's go to our next let's go
yes
um let's see what are the best
defrosting practices
and how do we deal with temporary
storage when the freezer is
defrosting
so um again like you will need to find
you know the equivalent temperature you
know available
in another unit probably to do a full
defrost
of say an ultra low or a negative 20
unit um
so hopefully there are some colleagues
in your building
or at your company that you can support
or your your
group could look at investing in
uh like a mobile freezer like what kathy
has at boulder
um to support this sort of effort in you
know ongoing in the future
um in terms of how to defrost um
for you know for example a negative 20
or an ultra low
you want to make sure to cut the power
to it in whatever
you know follow the instructions i guess
in your in your manual about how to do
that properly
because sometimes if you just pull the
plug it'll alarm
and you know that sort of thing or it'll
affect the battery so just make sure
you're following proper like
shutting off procedures for the unit so
once you've cleared out all your samples
turn it off and the one thing that we've
we have done
um a practice that we promote at boulder
is to do this like on a friday afternoon
you've cleared out your samples
unplugged the freezer open
prop open the door and just let it sit
all weekend
open drying out and sometimes put towels
or even better like cardboard on the
floor
underneath the door so that any moisture
that's falling out of the freezer
will get soaked up in the cardboard and
then you can you know that'll dry out
again and you can still recycle it
um so and then on monday
you've got you've got a dry freezer
that you can you know sanitize and turn
back on again
and i'll just add that you i'll just add
that um
you know obviously we have the mobile
freezers at cu boulder for the -20 needs
i mean this has been a
has been very popular among our
scientists they like to borrow our minus
20 freezers that are on the cart
but then also we've been really trying
hard
to get uh backup units when we've had
freezers that have been retired that are
still working
um you know we we keep them unplugged
but when there's a need such as a
defrost um
you know getting these units around
campus to locations where
they may not have access to such a
backup unit
and uh and providing these units as an
opportunity for labs in that area to be
able to plug that in and
and do a ultra temperature freezer
defrost
like christina described so we've been
really trying hard and so i mean knowing
on your campus or at your company where
backup resources are that you could
utilize uh is a great way but also to
christina's point to
to know um you know to connect with
other researchers that may have space
that you could borrow to do this as well
thank you both and that's great advice
and we always want to make sure we want
to remove the cardboard also
so we don't get any molds all right yeah
yes our next question um why do you
think more researchers
do not take advantage of centralized
storage resources
yeah i'll uh i'll take this one um my
opinion
uh well at least based upon what i've
been um working on at fu boulder to try
to move us
more in this direction where possible is
that it requires the help
and support and coordination from upper
levels of the university to eventually
get us there
and and so so if if a campus hasn't been
thinking in that way yet
for more of a campus-wide approach it's
going to be a bit of a struggle to get
there but if
uh campus has been if there are people
on that campus encouraging looking at
moving in this direction
um like like i have been at cu boulder
and other people have been at cu boulder
then that'll help us get over that that
hurdle to be able to hopefully get there
eventually because there are
as my presentation hopefully described
to you all that there are really uh you
know great cost avoidances efficient use
of space
and laboratory space is so expensive so
heading in distraction
direction really does lead to great
benefits to research
in my opinion but also great cost
avoidances
and better resilience for those units as
well
thank you and we have time for a few
more questions but before we continue i
do want to remind our audience that any
questions we are unable to answer live
today
and those that come in during the
on-demand period they will be addressed
by our speakers
and brooks life sciences via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration
okay let's continue can we apply
temperature tuning
in deep freezer negative 25 celsius
yeah i saw this uh this question come in
um
so because you know if you have a unit
at negative 25 degrees celsius
you know that's obviously a warmer
temperature than negative 70 or negative
80. and i haven't
i don't know if temperature tuning is
the right term if you would want to
change
that temperature on your unit um
but one thing that i think you should
consider is that other best practice i
was talking about
in this area which is to consider
whether all the samples in your negative
25 degree
unit actually need to be there um i
think that's
the best option as opposed to like
changing the set point of your freezer
so
determine if everything needs to be that
cold or if some things could be warmed
up to
refrigerator temperatures um i think i
think that's the best solution
i haven't really heard of people
changing the temperatures of their
negative 20s or negative 25 units
for energy efficiency purposes
we have though at cu boulder there have
been labs that have had
like negative 40 units that have
increased the temperature
to negative 30 or even negative 25
so we have had some labs do temperature
tuning even at these different
freezer temperatures and and at least
two of those units we did metering
before and after and there was
good energy savings and these are but
these are like lab grade units um
so they were they they did have a a
larger footprint than maybe a
residential one obviously but
but yeah so we have seen energy savings
at all also at these other temperatures
to do temperature tuning
now is there a universal method of
measuring the improved energy efficiency
well at cu boulder we've been lucky
um to work with our electrical engineers
on campus to set up a process
uh that that we use to do metering
um of the actual unit so we've mainly
just been
doing metering uh before and after
the the the temperature change and just
using that to compare
the difference um you know there we do
have a website
or web page on the green lab webpage
that is specific to minus 70 efforts i
didn't
include a link in the resources to that
but it does
like like the slide on in christina's
talk that showed the change in
consumption
and i assume christina that that report
that would have been from metering
before and after
um we've also done metering before and
after and so have
a number of institutions and we've been
adding um their their data to that
actually there's two pages those two
pages um
you know on on negative 70 efforts
um and and so we've been collecting that
in that location as
as as the data that supports the idea
that temperature tuning
does lead to energy savings
for the seal market assessments that
have been done
so the center for energy efficient
laboratories you know my green lab is
part of that partnership
that does these reports there have been
three or four reports that have come out
so far
and they're all on the my green lab
website under the seal
program if you want to take a look
for the one that was influential in
getting energy star ratings
for laboratory grade refrigerant
refrigerators and freezers
it was definitely like a standardized
energy star approved procedure
for you know measuring the energy
efficiency
of those units both at negative 70 um
and negative 80 degrees celsius um which
uh is how we got the data on
this slide um that you see here so um
yeah i i believe there are like test
method details
in the seal marcus market assessment on
ultra low temperature freezers
um so if you wanted to mimic those um
those are publicly available
thank you and because we're speaking of
efficiency here
could you please remind us how much
energy does a freezer actually use
um so i would say that you know it it
definitely varies
um based on the make and model and even
the age
of the freezer um but
uh so refrigerators often consume
one to two to three kilowatt hours per
day they're pretty
um pretty minimal compared to ultralows
um the same for negative 20 units you
can have
-20s that consume about two kilowatt
hours per day you can also have some
that consume a lot more for a variety of
reasons
whether that is they're not maintained
properly
they are totally iced over maybe they're
super empty inside for whatever reason
there are
you know at boulder um and i i did some
of the metering at boulder when i worked
there
you know for some reason some of those
units consume a lot more
than than they than the norm for that
category
ultra low temperature freezers though um
you know the ones that are energy star
rated um
consume from like eight to i don't know
what the upper range actually is for
what has energy star
but i would say like eight to 12
kilowatt hours per day is is pretty good
for an ultra low temperature freezer
um but but at cu boulder and you know
for
the seal market assessment they did
meter some that were consuming 25
or 30 or even more kilowatt hours per
day
um so there's a wide range and
um but yeah the energy star the energy
star approved
ultra low temperature freezers are all
going to be kind of in the same ballpark
um in terms of energy efficiency
yeah if i could add to that uh
you know the the residential like units
for -20 you know we've seen that
like christine is paying about two
kilowatt hours per day
um but you know there are lab grade
units that will consume more but
luckily we do now have energy star for
those units so that that's great because
some of the metering that
the cu green labs program did before the
energy star effort i mean we metered
some
um minus 20 lab grade units that were
used
one of them used i remember 13 kilowatt
hours per day and that was kind of an
extreme example but
i was shocked and i was like wow we have
some ultra lows on campus that are using
less than this minus 20.
um we've also metered like
chromatography refrigerators
and you know all of these units there's
a range
from our metering results and and by the
way we make our
metering results public so it's up on
our website
there's a link to this data that we've
been metering because some campuses
haven't been able to have the
opportunity to do metering
their campus so they can have access to
our data to justify projects and so
forth
but like chromatography refrigerators i
mean we were metering some at like 10
kilowatt hours per day or 12 kilowatt
hours per day so they were quite
consumptive
but you know this is a lot of this data
that i'm mentioning where we have these
really
energy consumptive units was happening
before the energy star effort came along
and i would say that's really moving the
market there wasn't as much attention
to energy efficiency for lab grade units
whether that
was um refrigerator lab grade
refrigerators slab grade freezers
um even chromatography refrigerators you
know there wasn't this attention to it
but
the market has really been shifting and
and there is more and more attention to
this now
and so we're we're you know now you know
if you were
to meet her you might find a unit that's
older but you also might
that's older and was around before the
enter energy star effort
or there still will be ones coming on
campus that haven't
gotten energy star or you know
work to reduce that consumption but in
general we're seeing just so many more
companies
that are putting products out there
paying attention to this and really
working on the energy efficiency of the
unit so
it's just really positive it's great to
see it's really
makes me happy
very good thank you for that detailed
answer now our next question and i'm
sure
this catching could come in from
multiple attendees
what do you do if your lab has the habit
of hoarding
i work in a medcam lab and we keep
compounds buffers and solutions
in our cold storage units there are some
things that
are not labeled but for the rest how can
we communicate this to our pis
since the holding cult hoarding culture
comes from before most of us
got to the lab
um well go ahead did you
do you want me to answer christina go
ahead
go ahead i was just going to say uh
you know this this question kind of
reminds me too
of the questions that i've typically
gotten with the green labs program is
what do you do when a lab doesn't want
to be engaged in your program
and to be honest i've just
there's been so many labs that have
wanted to do this i've been so impressed
with our scientists
um and i hear similar things of other
campuses there's so many
that want to do this that um
that that you know i focus on those that
want to be engaged
and that eventually those positive
examples
can influence the culture and other labs
that maybe
haven't been as engaged to do that
because
it moves from just being an and
you know a couple of labs doing this to
more and more labs doing this
to becoming something that the
department's doing and that culture
moves along
and so i don't know um you know
with within a particular lab though i
mean if you're a member of that lab
that's hard um but setting that example
maybe just as
one person in the lab and sharing what
you're doing to be efficient and then
seeing if there's another person
that was also willing to be do their
part to be efficient
and seeing if you can grow that culture
internally
uh within the lab over time
you know as i mentioned culture shifts
can take time so
um you know if there's there's efforts
like that that you can do
i have seen on my campus
just labs that really in the beginning
would avoid
um you know me when i walk down the hall
but that with the the cultural shift
within the building and
and that over time those labs
have turned into some of our most
engaged labs
so this culture shift is slow it takes
time as a building process and um
building through examples i think is a
good way
to try to move that and i hope that
answered your question
christine i don't know if you have
anything to add i mean you were so
um
yeah i mean one one thing that comes to
mind is you know if you're
if you're in a lab that is hoarding
reagents samples
in in cold storage units um
i think maybe approaching that issue in
your laboratory from the perspective
of i'm unable to be effective
as a scientist because i say
you know there's a lot of stuff in the
freezer that i don't know what it is or
the refrigerator
whatever it might be there's a lot of
stuff that i don't know what it is and i
have to dig
through it to get my own stuff we're
leaving the door open
if you frame it from like a resiliency
standpoint that might
um get through to your your pi a little
bit better
um another idea is you know to talk with
them about
cost so um you know
if your lab is hoarding stuff and things
are really
full you know you could share that like
instead of buying another unit which
will cost
ten thousand twelve thousand fifteen
thousand dollars and be a significant
expense for the lab
if you all just took some time to kind
of sort through what you have
might be able to free up space and
eliminate that
that you know costs that will be coming
down the line
if your lab doesn't take action with
their with their cold storage
so those are just a couple ideas too if
you need to frame it differently
to appeal to what's important to your pi
um obviously you know trying to be
energy efficient
is great and um you know doing your best
on that front but that doesn't always
speak to everybody so trying to frame it
in a different way might help
thank you both so much for this
excellent q a session we are out of time
and we had a significant amount of
questions that we are when
we are unable to answer during this live
event but i just do want to remind our
audience that those questions we didn't
answer
and those that come in during the
on-demand period they will be addressed
by our speakers
and our team at brooks life sciences via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration
i once i would like to once again thank
dr kathy ramirez aguilar and christina
griever for their time today and their
important contribution to reducing
environmental footprint of freezer use
and research
um do either of you have any final
comments for our audience
yeah i really appreciate it go ahead oh
sorry christina go ahead
oh that's okay okay
i know um so christina here um with my
green lab
and i just want to you know mention if
you do have any you know follow-up
questions that you didn't get in you
know you can
submit them and we'll answer them during
the on-demand period for the webinar
um please visit the my green lab website
if you're curious more about what we do
we have many different programs the
freezer challenge is just one of them
like the lab certification i mentioned
we do some work on green chemistry
the act label which is all about
sustainable procurement so we have a lot
to offer
um you can sign up for our monthly
newsletter and
on our website and then we're also on
twitter facebook and linkedin
so and i manage that social media so if
you interact with us
you're interacting with me for the most
part and um that'd be really great
moving forward
and thanks again everybody for for
listening in on this
again i just wanted to thank everyone as
well for listening in
um you know working on efficient cold
storage has been so rewarding at cu
boulder and
and i and i hope that you'll find the
same on your campus
uh and if you're interested in more you
can visit the
the cu green labs um page uh and we have
lots of resources on freezers
and and many other efforts as well and
and i also encourage you
to attend the i2sl conference in chicago
in in
october so it's really a
fun and and grassroots in many way
experience and and so just there's so
much passion
around sustainability and labs i i just
love going every year
and and hearing about all the great
efforts that people are doing and one of
the
nicest things about i2sl conference is
that you're getting such a diverse
range of stakeholders attending i mean
it includes engineers designers
architects
but also safety folks and and
individuals like christina and i working
on with scientists and also scientists
sometimes
come as well so i encourage you to
attend and share what you're doing
thank you both and thank you to
labyrinths and our sponsor brooks life
sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
if you are interested in receiving your
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits this webcast can be viewed on
demand and you may continue to submit
questions
during the on-demand period laborats
will alert you via email when today's
presentation is available for replay and
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now and we hope to see
you again soon
stay safe stay healthy and have a great
day